ouais là on a des comédiens autour de la
drogue sûr que ça fasse un pic
d'audience à poil camille d'achat qui
s'y prend mais j'ai un truc à te à te
confier je dois dire d'abord que c'est
franck qui m'a forcé non je m'appelle
pas natation sissi duparc c'est-à-dire
l'actrice qui dit toujours oui c'est ici
[Rires]
téléspectateurs depuis tout à l'heure et
a fait savoir qu'il ne dit pas dire
bonjour à natacha bonjour à la 10e'
s'appelle la tâche à aller dire bonjour
natacha dupas voilà donc il est très
content bien pris voilà la mise en échec
a mis à poil ça vient de faire ces pas
c'est pas payant ce jour c'est vrai pas
c'est quoi ta bave d'en haut mais
peut-être en bas
je crois pas
[Applaudissements]
ça te va
je pense
c'est pourquoi l'école salle à la paz où
jean-michel merde oui j'ai senti quelque
chose au niveau des cuisses c'est vrai
ah oui enfin d'apache aller dans des
films comme dans la vie il n'appelle pas
la tâche n'a pas fait mais c'est mon
double diabolique mais nom d'actrice et
sissi duparc d'accord exactement merci à
vous appeler sapel madame